in terms of
this line between learning and thinking
through a new thing
that seems to be deeply uh connected
there's this
legendary engineer named jim keller who
keeps yelling at me about this he says
it's very effective
he likes to for difficult problems
before bed think about that difficult
problem we're not talking about like
drama at work or all that kind of stuff
no like a scientific for him engineering
problem
he likes to like intensely think about
it
and to prime his mind yes before sleep
and then go to sleep and then uh he
finds that
the next day
he's he's able to think much clearer and
there's new ideas that come but also
just i guess it's more well integrated
um and sometimes during the process of
like he's able to like wake up
and
like
see new insights that's right if he's
deeply sort of aggressively thinking
through a problem
and there's many scientific you know
demonstrations of this you know the
mendeleev with a periodic table of
elements you know he was trying for
months to understand i mean talk about
an
ecumenical problem of epic proportions
here's your question today
you have to understand how all of the
known elements in the universe fit
together in a logical way good luck take
it was non-trivial at the time and he
would try and try he was so obsessed
with it he created playing cards with
all of the different elements on and
then he would go on these long train
journeys around europe and he would just
sort of deal these cards in front of
them and he would shuffle them
shuffling and shuffling and he would
just try to see if he could find what
the answer was and then so the story
goes you know he fell asleep and he had
a dream and in that dream you know all
of these elements started to dance and
play around and they snapped into a
logical grid you know atomic weights etc
etc
and it wasn't his waking brain
that
solved the problem it was his sleeping
brain that solved the impenetrable
problem that his waking brain could not
and there's been count you know even in
the arts and in music
some wonderful dreams you know
frankenstein mary shelley's epic gothic
novel came to her in a dream at lord
byron's home
and then we've got
you know
paul mccartney
um yesterday the song came to him in a
dream he was
filming um
gosh what was the movie um i don't
recall it i should be shocked because
i'm from liverpool myself
and
but he was on wimpole street in london
and filming and they he came up with
that song the melody um in his sleep not
to be outdone by the beatles and by the
way let it be um also came from a dream
that mccartney had people usually give
it you know religious overtones you know
mother mary comes to me speaking words
of wisdom let it be
if you've ever asked who mother mary is
it's not the you know the biblical
content
it's his
his mother it's it's it's mary mccartney
yeah and she came to him in a dream and
gifted him the song
but the best story i've heard is um not
to be outdone by the beatles the stones
um keith richards
who i think once was suggested that
who was it was a comedian who was saying
that
in
an interview with rolling stone keith
richards suggested or inferred that
young kids should not do drugs
and they said well look
young kids can't do drugs because you've
done all of that
but um keith richards described uh
he would always go to bed with his um
guitar
and a tape recorder um and then probably
who would have a whole
set of other things in the bed with him
and who knows how many other people but
anyway uh and then he said in his
autobiography and i'm paraphrasing here
but
one morning i woke up and i realized
that the tape had recorded all the way
to the end so i rewound the tape
and i hit play
and there in some kind of ghostly form
with the opening chords to satisfaction
the most famous successful rolling stone
song of all of all time
yeah
followed by then 43 minutes of snoring
that riff came to him one of the most
famous riffs in all of rock and roll
came to him by way of a dream inspired
insight so i think you know
there is
too many of those anecdotes and we've
now got the sight you know i don't rely
on anecdotes as science we've now done
the studies in the laboratory and we can
reliably demonstrate that sleep inspires
creativity inspires problem-solving
capacity well the interesting thing is
is it possible to some of the ideas that
you talk about to turn them into a
protocol that can be practiced
rigorously so what jim keller
espouses is
saying not just the fact that sleep
helps you
increase the creativity but turn it into
a process like literally
like don't do it accidentally you know
like
uh like an athlete does certain things
to optimize their performance they have
a training routine they have a regimen
of uh
of like cycling and and uh sprints and
long distance stuff in the same way
thinking about your
job as an idea generator in the
engineering space is like this is good
for my performance so like for an hour
before bed
think through a problem like every night
and then
use sleep to uh
work through that problem i mean that
he's the first person that i heard like
of the people i really respect that do
like what i do which is like programming
engineering type work
like using
sleep not accidentally but with a
purpose
like using sleep
you know that's just basically the
difference between as you said a passive
approach to it versus
you know an
active deterministic or hope for a
deterministic approach to it in other
words that you are actually trying to
harness
the power of of sleep in a deliberate
way rather than an unthoughtful way i
still think that you know mother nature
through it you know 3.6 million years of
evolution has probably got it
mostly figured out in terms of what
information should be uploaded at night
and worked through i think her algorithm
is probably pretty good at this stage
it's not to suggest though that you know
we can't try to tweak it and nudge it
you know it's a very light hand on the
tiller is is what he's doing i i don't
think there's anything wrong with that
you know just like for example for me
fasting has improved my ability to focus
deeply and productivity significantly
and in that same way
you know it's possible that playing with
these ideas of thinking before bed or
some hours before better some
playing with different protocols will
have a significant leap over what mother
nature naturally does so if you let your
body do what it actually does you may
not achieve the same level of
performance because mother nature
has not designed us to think deeply
about uh chip design
for uh
programming artificial intelligence
systems so well she's gifted us the
architecture and the capacity to do that
what we do with that is
you know is what life's experience
dictates
she gives us the blueprint to do many
you know well if i were to sort of
introspect and self-analyze what mother
nature wants me to do i think given my
current lifestyle that i have food in
the fridge
and a bed to sleep on i think what
mother nature wants me to do is to be
lazy
and so i think i'm actually resisting
mother nature uh
in
because so many of my knees are
satisfied and so i i'm
i have to resist some of the natural
forces of the body and the mind when i
do some of the things i do so there's
that dance
um you know like i've been thinking
about doing a startup and that's
obviously going against everything that
my body and mind
are telling me to do because it's going
to be basically suffering
but the only reason why as you know it
will be over
yes
i but nevertheless there's some kind of
inner drive that wants me to do it and
then you start to ask a question well
how do you optimize the things you can't
optimize like sleep like diet like the
people that you surround yourself with
in order to
maximize happiness and performance and
all those kinds of things without also
over optimizing and that's such an
interesting idea from
from a
engineer so
as you may know you don't often
get that those kinds of ideas from
engineers engineers usually just don't
read books about sleeping
they're usually like the the
they're not they they're not the
healthiest of people
um i think that's changing over time
especially silicon valley especially the
tech sector people are starting to
understand what's a healthy lifestyle
but usually they're kind of on the
insane side especially programmers but
it's nice to hear uh somebody like that
use sleep and use some of the things you
talk about strategically
on purpose
you know to that idea of
not just
trying to use what mother nature
gave but
seeing if you can do something more or
different
in a conservative mindset
i would then pose the question at what
cost
because when you
do something perhaps that deviates from
the typical pre-programmed
you know
mother nature's program um
i suspect it usually comes at the cost
of something else so maybe he is you
know able to direct and focus his
sleeping cognition
on those particular topics that will
gain him better problematic resolution
the next day when he wakes up the
question is though at what cost of the
other things that didn't make it onto
the menu
of
the finger buffet of sleep that night
and is it that you don't process the
emotional difficulties or events and
therefore you are less emotionally
resolved the next day but you are more
problem resolved the following day and
so i always try to think and
i i truly don't want to sound
puritanical either about sleep and i
think i've come off that way
many a time especially when i started
out in the public
the tone of the book in some ways you
know i look back and think could i have
been a little softer
and the reason was i i was that way
back in when i started writing the book
which was probably something like
2014 or 15
sleep was the neglected stepsister in
the health conversation of the day and i
was just so sad to see the amount of
suffering and disease and sickness that
was caused by insufficient sleep
and for years before i'd been you know
doing public speaking and i'd tell
people about the great things that
happen when you get sleep people would
say that's fascinating and then they
would go back and keep doing the same
thing about not sleeping enough and then
i realized you can't really speak about
the good things that happen it's like
the news what bleeds leads and if you
speak about the alarmingly bad things
that happen people tend to have a
behavioral change
and so the book as a consequence i think
probably came out
a little bit on the strong side of
you know trying to convince you know
people we're trying to help a lot of
people and that's a powerful way to help
a lot of people i would i was genuinely
trying to help people but you know
certainly for some people who for whom
sleep is not does not come easy then it
was probably you know
a tricky book to read too and i think i
i feel more sensitive to those people
now and empathetically connected to them
um
so i think the
again the point was simply that i don't
mean to sound too
puritanical in in all of this and the
same way with
you know caffeine and coffee
i am just a scientist and i am not here
to tell anyone how to live their life
that is not my job at all and life is to
be lived to a degree and life is to be
lived if you want to do a startup
all i want to do is empower people with
the understanding of the science of
sleep and then you can make an informed
choice as to how you want to live your
life and i often no judgement on how
anyone wishes to live their life i just
want to try and
see if the information that i have about
sleep would alternatively change how you
would think about your life decisions
and if it doesn't no problem and if it
does
i hope it's been of use
you